he's JJ Watt the Texans defensive end
joining us on the program once last time
you called in sick um practice or a game
I I haven't called in sick to a game the
sickest I've ever been was I got a staph
infection in 2015 two days before game
in Jacksonville and we had IVs I had to
go to the emergency room get a three
hour IV there had to go to fly to
Jacksonville get a three hour IV in the
hotel room there and then they woke me
up at 6:00 a.m. to get to our IV before
the game so that was one of the one of
the most miserable feelings I've ever
had but I don't know if I don't think
I've ever missed a game for sickness on
a scale of one to ten how sick were you
in that Jacksonville game oh man I mean
it was it was pretty rough and it was
hot it was hot out there it was it was
it was a telephone I mean that was one
where I recovering after the game you
know you just know for no amount of
fluid and food was innocent but you know
that's part of the game I do you guys
eat at halftime
uh no not like you know you have
Gatorade or electrolytes or I mean it
actually sounds funny to say it out loud
but there are orange slices available
whose mom brings those but I mean they
have an array of stuff you know bananas
I think a banana is a big thing at
halftime you know that's if you're gonna
eat something or you feel like you know
just blow up at is good or they have
some peanut butter and jelly sandwiches
and stuff like that but for the most
part I don't think a lot of guys you
have that so no chicken tenders or
anything like that no not unless it's
the fourth preseason game you're just
flying across by the way we got a plan
our schedule so I don't know when the
wedding is but I you know I'm a busy guy
and there's yeah I know yeah so
limitation was just the nail up there
must not be working properly well I have
a new studio so maybe we went to the old
studio I bet that has to be it by the
way the mancave looks unbelievable that
place is incredible
yeah it's good yeah and you know maybe
you guys could honeymoon up here if
you'd like we were thinking about
holding the reception or actually a
booth you know we could have contests
for all the guests we could have a free
throw contest you know get in the
Callaway simulator and have some golf
shots I got a trailer grill I got I'll
get in Friday yes if we can get a beat
Friday
waiting okay
maybe you guys how about you and your
fiance do a meet Friday song for us well
I can't sing and I could come up with
the lyrics a lot of jalapeno sausage
gonna be tossing us Texas brisket yeah
barbecue there so JJ Watt joining us how
was it playing against your brother
it was interesting I mean it was really
cool I mean before the game being able
to see him see his sons and his wife my
parents have those moments and then
during the game you know for the first
the very first time he was on the field
the same time as me you kind of look
over there it's just it's interesting
and cool but then as the game goes on
you really don't even realize it I know
it but he did chip me in the ribs one
time and I know I knew that but then
there was another play where he actually
kind of peeled black back and tried to
block me and I didn't even know about
that play until we watched it and film
yesterday so you just kind of get back
into the flow of the game and don't
realize it but I mean after the game and
on the plane ride home just thinking
about how incredible and how crazy that
that is it really was special
okay but do you you go out of your way
to hit him harder
no but like there's like a third and one
and there's a fullback belly and you
know he's got a chance to get in the
ball so I'm a DN so I'm a little too far
away to get there but I definitely was
trying to get down in there like I
wanted to get in on that tackle but I
was I couldn't I was too far away if I
put all three of you guys in the Octagon
so Derek and TJ in the Octagon
yeah who makes you nervous nobody the
interesting thing about us is is that
like we had it we had all of our battles
of kids so as many hockey sticks in the
basement and you know you'd smoke each
other in the back of the leg with a
video slam somebody into the wall and
but anytime it was anybody outside of us
we were a hundred percent on the same
side and now that we're growing up like
we'll text each other every single day
we'll text each other on game day and
it's it's nothing but love so it's not
like that there's any the only
competition comes in the way from
running and jumping
so like PJ can jump the same as me but
he can do some cooler dunks on a
basketball court than I can so I have to
concede to him in that Derrick's
probably the smartest of us three so we
each have our thing when they're a
moment with a holding call that wasn't
called and then the officials said hey I
know he's holding you but basically
sorry because I think there's so many
holdings I think the penalties are up
66% and holding from last year but now
they're not gonna call as many so what
do you make of all today I think this
week they were back down I think there's
a phone call but they had this weekend
in their back down so you know you just
got to play the game the way the game is
being played and I guess that's you know
I've been doing that I was in the whole
career and you just have to figure it
out early in the game and understand
what their call it and hope that you get
the fair calls when they're when they're
being called and you know try to have a
conversation with the referee to make
sure that you understand like he's tall
he understands what you're going through
and if there's something that you're
whether it's hands or the face or
holding or something you just let him
know so you can at least look out for it
at the end of the day it's just find the
ball and get the ball and whatever
happens along the way you just have to
deal with it we have an idea of putting
gloves mittens on offensive linemen so
they they wouldn't be able to hold like
boxing look great what do you think
great let's do that I'm not on any
committees or anything but if there were
a committee for that I'd be on it it'd
be great you know
would you wear mittens I mean I wouldn't
prefer it no but if they had to no no
I'm just saying if you know if we
expanded this you know they offensive
linemen may complain and then I can say
hey look the defensive linemen have to
wear gloves as well I wore so that same
2050s he and I broke my head and I had
to wear a club so I couldn't use any of
my fingers that's very annoying so I
wouldn't I definitely wouldn't enjoy it
but I'd consider it yeah but you really
can't do anything I mean you can't grab
you can't and you'd be surprised at how
much stuff that you need like obviously
you know try to get around the corner
and grab dinner but there's so many
little things that you actually use your
hands for do you think one day you and
your wife look back and you go I can't
believe I played with that injury or why
did I continue to be I did think of you
when Andrew Luck walked away I thought
of you because you've been through so
much and that rehab process as we know
is so lonely but and we don't see it and
so when Andrew Luck walked away I don't
know what you thought when he walked
away I'm curious about that I had an
immense amount of respect for his
decision I mean to know how much thought
and how much went into that and it's I
mean that's an unbelievably difficult
decision I mean you have to think about
not only walking away from multi multi
billions of dollars he's also walking
away from a game that he loves and again
that he's played for so long
teammates and guys in the locker room
you know an organization in a city that
is looking at him to be their guy and
for him to be able to sit there and say
you know what I understand all that
but I need to do what's best for me in
my body in my health in my mind you know
I have so much respect for him to be
able to sit down and truly make that
decision and it it it's not easy to do I
can definitely tell you that how close
did you come
to return um I think yeah I think I
probably made it sound public being more
close than I actually was and when I
look back on it I think that's probably
something that I probably I was probably
overdramatic about it because I was
going through a lot of stuff but I was
still I'm still young so it's not like I
was you know it's not like I was 33
going through a broken leg point is I
think I made it seem a little worse than
it was because I was I honestly was
thinking those things but I think when I
look back on it I didn't need to be
thinking those things you know
did you did you get an honorary degree a
medical degree from Baylor University a
doctor a doctor and I'm still upset that
you haven't addressed me as such yet
doctoring a lot okay did you get this
because of all your surgeries yeah
because I did them all myself which is
why the first practice to try to figure
it out I got you what do you know how
many quarterback hits you have since you
came into the league I think keeps down
that's that's that's the right answer
because you shouldn't know that you did
that's where you go no I just play
football 250 quarterback hits 2nd on
that low is Von Miller he has 54 fewer
quarterback hitch than you make you feel
good all right
sure I like hitting the quarterback like
you know like stop doing that or that
was mean or that hurt
no but this week no this week so I got I
got a sack out Phillip Rivers in the
second quarter half a sack I think it's
whole thing and half and I was obviously
excited about it we were all excited
about it in the very next play he did a
hard count in all of us on the line
jumps outside Sydney everybody we were
all outside and immediately after the
play he pointed to me he goes watch you
celebrate that why don't you celebrate I
didn't really have much like I mean yeah
he got
oh yeah so it was it was funny he's one
of the smartest guys another played
against and he's a lot of fun to play
against because he's so smart and kind
of knows what everybody's doing at all
times that was a funny moment and he's
not afraid to talk no no he's not and
he's in that stadium you can obviously
hear more than you can in other stadiums
it you can hear every single thing that
he's calling out you can hear everything
so it's really it was honestly really
interesting to me to just hear him
communicate everything and to hear him
calling out so much and to hear how much
he truly knows about it the opposing
team's defense and we're gonna suppose
line alcohol covered him and he just he
knows and it was really really
impressive good luck against the
Panthers and I will we will see you at
the reception
open bar right thanks guys I appreciate
it hello toad and that's back there guys
have a wonderful day I appreciate you
having me open bar always the only way
to go I like that
and so JJ want four more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]